[Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  our team is the elite of the elite the  heart soul of this very big issue  we protect when no one wants to protect  and we go above and beyond and then tell  me what saving people you know  refrigerator oh that's a very wash you  put me it's more than this job than just  swimming  Victoria leads the new owner on success  Josh murder all this started when police  took over I thought we were lifeguards  everything that you guys talking about  sounds like a really entertaining but  far-fetched TV show  I destroyed running it all up you see it  too  you can be a Baywatch [ __ ]  for my ham  you turned the canals into the goddamn X  game yeah that's because we were in  lifeguard pursuit there's no [ __ ]  such thing as lifeguard pursuit even if  you were believed what you did would  still be totally illegal okay well I  mean it's good thing we're not police  you